- [Kelly] You are adorable.
- You are
- [Kelly] You walked out
looking like a modern version
of Pearl Harbor-esque,
I'm into everything that's
happening right now.
- Wait, I'm not sure that's a compliment.
- It is, that's my favorite.
That's my favorite look.
- Oh, the forties. You like that?
- Yeah. Yeah. Just that whole...
Yeah, that time wasn't good.
Maybe I should think of another reference.
Maybe I'll go forties next time.
So wait, you guys know each other, right?
- Yes. We've worked together a few times.
- Did you like it?
- Yes, of course.
- [Jake] We loved it.
- She goes Jake is so talented.
- Oh, I've worked with him a few times.
But we did Hoops together,
an animated show, and we
got to do a love scene
via voiceover together where
I was in a one-piece suit.
And you somehow take the
suit off or something
- And, well yeah, we had to do a sex scene
but like over voiceover.
But I'm a method actor,
so I was like in the booth,
very committed.
- But you were so good on that show.
It's so funny
that one of the most
disgusting characters ever...
You crushed it.
Truly.
- Once again, I don't
know if it's a compliment.
- It is, it is.
- The other time we worked together, too
I played a disgusting character.
- Oh yeah, that's right.
- That's kind my thing.
- Is this a theme?
- Yeah, I sort of invented
like the pantsless woman
character, who's the comedian.
- [Kelly] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Kelly] America says thank you.
So wait, so Jacob
mentioned his wife's closet
earlier, so,
- [Natasha] Yes.
- Here's yours.
I just thought we should show.
- [Natasha] Oh yeah.
Okay, can I just talk about
this though for a second?
- [Kelly] Was there an earthquake or like
- Well, okay, here's the thing, you know,
- [Kelly] Were you robbed?
(all laughing)
- Like I was robbed one time
and my closet looked like that.
- It honestly looks worse now.
I'm mean I here's,
- Oh my God, I love you.
- [Natasha] No, here's
what's happening, you know?
All right.
You know, like young
girls will go on Instagram
and they will look at
all the beautiful images
of these women.
And then they'll get like body dysmorphia.
Yeah. Like I have that on Instagram,
but for houses like looking
at people's pristine houses,
like I follow all of these people,
and I just I've given up, like I can't.
Like Gwyneth Paltrow,
did you see her house?
It's like, she has literally has a couch.
That is a swing in her living room.
Like where's the goop Gwyneth?
Like doesn't goop mean
dirt, like why this is real
- Like my and my kids would
that would not be a good
plan in my living room.
- [Natasha] The swing?
- The swing.
- What is that?
- Yeah, and what kind of swing is it?
- I don't, it, it looks like
- Like how exciting is Gwyneth Paltrow,
swings in her living room?
I was like, wait, what?
I was like, that's amazing.
Anyway. So wait you're
we're gonna talk about
your new cooking show.
So it's called "Rat In The Kitchen".
So there's one person
who sabotages the dishes
but what kind of happens
what's the whole premise?
- So it's kind of like
Knives Out" meets "Top Chef".
- [Kelly] Love "Knives Out".
- So it's like a murder mystery,
but also a cooking show.
So me and Chef Ludo, who
I think was on your show.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- He's an amazing French
chef, but everyone's,
each episode these chefs
are trying to impress this
like world renowned Michelin Star chef.
But what they don't know is like, well
they know someone's the rat,
but they don't know who it is.
So they're all trying to
figure out who is the rat.
So if the food's disgusting
then we know the rat has gotten a hold
of it and the rat gets
the money for that round.
And then if it's great
then the team gets it,
and then eventually the team will win.
- Do you ever spit it out?
Like right on camera?
- I have, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I would too.
- Unfortunately.
- I know it feels rude, but
whatever's gonna happen.